[Musique]
s'arrêter quelque part pour la nuit
je suis fatigué hé nous suggérons juste que nous mangions
aujourd'hui j'ai acheté ici environ 20 miles il y a
un endroit qui s'appelle Helen combien
vaut-elle pour toi nous allons juste l'oublier
d'accord Hey
[Musique]
juste un peu de torture et nous
aurons et des chiffres de toutes sortes ce qui se
passe Len l'a trouvée le coffre
de la voiture qu'il a qui vient de moi
il va venir et il vous tous
les 14 étudiants avaient été brutalement assassinés
un seul  n'a jamais été trouvé
c'est vous dans les voitures du conducteur beaucoup
de cadets tout ce trafic est mon meilleur
espoir d'évasion est bien il vous tue
oh je suis monsieur - vous faites
allez
[Musique]
personne ne vous vit